we're gonna get going eventually my
dog's gonna commit in three seconds
Italy where is your dog my dog is here
we gotta get the dog in the shop it's
okay you can sip I think we if you know
you this is easy this is like an easy
relaxed interview listen like I'm just
still going we're just having a good
time here all right all right you are
dressed for the occasion I am it works
the occasion you're an action star okay
things have fallen and you're saving
them so I gotta wear this shirt it's
appropriate stuff is falling I put on my
favorite shirt so this is the third
installment is there anything that you
would like to see is there anything on a
dreamless that you're like I would love
for this city to fall so I can catch it
no that's the whole point about this one
was we moved away from a city you know
the first one was the White House in
Washington the second one we managed to
close down all of London and then this
one we thought what if the whole thing
turns in in itself and it's not a city
but it's the guardian angel himself the
one who's done all that good work is now
turned against set up and and and is on
the run and has everybody after him
everyone yeah but he's still like he's
still gonna get to the end and find out
what the hell's going on and you know
yeah you know and you know and you know
because we know we know everything
Morgan Freeman the president Oh Morgan
people the actor morning yeah in the
film you're also in yeah you are working
to save him there's a lot of stunts
between the two of you I want to know if
you sustained any injuries making this
film Oh
III always sustained injuries on on
movies I came into this movie beaten up
to be honest because I just had a more I
had to push the movie three months
because I just had a motorcycle crash
and bust up my my feet and I am so it
was an interesting start to the movie
but you always get bumps and bruises and
pull things and that's part of it by the
way and to be honest weirdly it helps
because you play in an action role where
you're getting injured as you go through
the movie so rather than having to go I
am imagining a painful hip you're like
how am I gonna get through the day like
how am I gonna get through this story so
yeah that Morgan was by the way he's a
true action star I don't think he's ever
done action like he did in this movie
and it was kind of crazy because I fell
a bit responsible for that because I'm
running with them we're running upstairs
really fast people firing guns out is
throwing them behind cars throwing them
into offices into the water diving down
as deep as we can holding him underwater
help like if anything goes wrong I am
gonna be the guy who killed Morgan
Freeman our national treasure oh my gosh
is there any action star that you would
love to collaborate with like there's
you know new-school people like Will
Smith Dwayne Johnson then there's like
the classic Stallone Arnold anyone you
want to save the world with that saved
the way you know who I'd love to do a
movie with I think we would have fun I
love them as a guy - is Jason Statham
him and I often say you know we should
get together and do me I think him and I
would be great together because whenever
we we meet we have such a blast you know
and I think that that would be a great
energy on screen but I'd work with a lot
of those guys you know I don't think the
rock could handle me you know I think
I'm just too big now it's who built for
him you know and just the charisma is
gonna overpower unless it's what's the
Iike trying yeah